The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: OK, let us start.
So first, let me
remind you what we did
at the end of the last lecture.
So we can see there's a
large N matrix field theory.
And then we saw that when
you write down your Feynman
diagrams to calculate
things, then
there's a difference now between
the order of contractions.
Which is now
refracted whether you
have a Planar diagram or
non-planar diagram, et cetera.
And that in turn, also
affects your end counting.
So at the end, we
discussed two observations.
One observation we said, is for
the example to be considered is
the non-planar diagram, even
though it cannot be drawn
on the plane without
crossing lines,
can actually be drawn on the
torus without crossing lines.
So the diagram can actually be
straightened out on the torus.
And another observation,
is that the power of N
is related to the number of
faces you have in your diagram
after you have
straightened it out.
So now, I'm going to generalize
these two observations.
So first, I will
tell you a fact.
Many of you may
already know this.
So I'll first tell you a
fact that any orientable two
dimensional surface is
classified topologically
by integer, which I will call h.
So this h is called a genus.
So heuristically, this genus
is equal to the number of holes
a surface has.
So for example, if
you have a plane,
the plane topologically
is actually
equivalent to a
sphere, so when I
draw a sphere,
that means a plane,
because if you
identify the point
on the plane of the infinity,
then it becomes a sphere.
So topologically, a plane is
no different from a sphere.
So this genus 0.
So this is plane.
So h is equal to 0.
And then for torus,
then there's one hole,
and this is just genus 1.
So this is torus.
You can also draw surfaces
with as many holes as you want.
So this is surface
with two holes.
A surface with two holes,
and so this is genius 2.
So the remarkable thing
is that this actually
classifies the topology of
all two-dimensional surfaces.
And this so-called
topological invariant,
there's a topological number
a so-called Euler number,
which is defined to be Chi
is equal to 2 minus 2h.
So if h labels the
topology, and so the Chi
is related to h in this way.
So any two surfaces
with the same topology
will have the same Chi, because
if they have the same h,
they have the same Chi.
So Chi is what we call the
topological invariants.
So this is just a
mathematical fact.
So now I'm going
to make two claims.
So these two claims
are in some sense,
still evident after you
have studied a little bit.
I'm not going to prove it
here, will just make the claim,
and then I will leave the
task to familiarize these two
claims to yourself.
But as I said, these two claims
are actually self-evident,
if you just do a
little bit of studying.
So claim one-- so
this is regarding
the structural Feynman diagrams.
So remember, the example
theory we conceded last time
was something like this, which
phi is [INAUDIBLE] matrix.
So if you can look at
the Feynman diagrams
of the theories, the
claim is the following.
for any non-planar
diagram, there
exists integer h
so that the diagram
can be straightened out.
Straightened out just means
non-crossing on a genus h
surface, but not on a
surface with a smaller genus.
So actually, you can classify
all the non-planar diagrams
by drawing it on
a genus h surface
on two-dimensional surfaces
with non-trivial topology.
And then you should be able
to find the number h, which
is the lowest genus you
need to make this diagram
to be non-crossing,
instead of crossing.
Last time, we saw an example
which you can stretch it out
on the torus, but it was
a more complicated diagram
and torus would not be enough.
You would need, say, a genus
2 surface or higher genus
surface.
So you can easily
convince yourself
that this is doable
just by some practice.
Also, this is very reasonable.
Do you have any questions
regarding this claim?
Good.
So this was claim one.
The claim two-- and
this is a generalization
of the second observation.
It's a claim of
the generalization
of the first observation
of last time,
and claim two will
be the generalization
of the second observation.
For any diagram, the power
of n coming from contracting
propagators is given
by the number of faces
on such a genus h surface.
As we explained last
time, the number of faces
just means the number of
these connected regions
in the diagram.
But if you are
stretching it out,
then there's an
ambiguous way you
can count the number
of disconnected regions
In the diagram.
And that number is the power of
n coming from the contracting
propagators.
So this claim is
also self-evident
because each power of n comes
from a single connected line.
And essentially, a
single connected line
will be circles some face and
so the number of independents
inside the face of course, are
just the number of power n.
Any questions regarding
the second claim?
Good.
So based on these two claims,
now immediately write down
the independents.
So from this, we can
find a vacuum diagram.
Again, we have been only talking
about the vacuum diagram.
Vacuum diagram means the
diagram has no external lags,
has the full independence.
So from here, we
immediately conclude
that the vacuum diagram has
the following, g squared
and dependence.
So g squared is just
the carpeting constant.
So remember, each propagator
is proportional to g squared
and that each vertex
is one over g squared.
Just from there.
So let's just take an
arbitrary vacuum diagram.
Let me call this amplitude
to be A. And A should
be proportional to g
squared to the power
E. E should be the
number of propagators,
because each propagator gives
you a factor of g squared.
And also minus V.
And V is the number
of vertices below to
the number of vertices.
And each vertex gives
you one over g squared,
so that should
give you E minus V.
And then we just multiply
N to the power of F,
and F is the number of faces.
So without doing
any calculation,
so this has essentially
characterized the N and the g
and the accompanying
dependents of any diagrams.
Now, if you look
at this expression,
you say we are doomed, because
this kind of expression
does not have a
sensible [INAUDIBLE]
So remember our goal, the
original goal of the 't Hooft
is that you treat
this N as a parameter
and then you want to
take it N to be large
and then to it's ranking, one
over N. Doing expansion in one
over N means you are expanding
around the including infinity.
You want to expand around
the including infinity.
But if you look
at this expression
and then go to infinity, it's
not a well-defined limit,
because I can draw a [INAUDIBLE]
Feynman diagram, which
F can be as large as possible.
So you just have
sufficiently many vertices,
and sufficient to be mainly
propogators, F is unbounded.
So then, there's another
well-defined angle
to infinity limits.
So this expression is not a
sensible N of infinity limit.
If you don't have a
sensible N infinity limit,
then you cannot talk about
doing a longer expansion,
and you cannot even define
the limit we just finished.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I remember people
do partial sum to-- can
they do the same thing here?
Put the large in the
denominator pattern from series
of singular bubbles and--
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like a random
face approximation--
HONG LIU: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Somehow they
can infinite a sum
over an infinite number
of A, and put the margin
into like 1 minus N something
for the denominator--
HONG LIU: Yeah.
So people certainly have
been talking about expansion.
And certainly, if
this just failed here,
we will not be
talking about this.
I'm just setting
up a target, which
I'm going to shoot it down.
Right.
Yeah, I would just say if
you do the margin expansion,
this probably would be the
place which would turn you back.
You say, ah, there's
no margin limits,
and that's from another problem.
But hopefully, that's
no ordinary person.
And so remember, there are
several nice mathematical
tricks you have to go through.
First, you have to invent the
stop line notation so that you
can count the end very easily.
Yeah, first you have to come
up with this margin idea.
I think maybe not due to
him, maybe other people
already considered similar
things like right here.
But first you have to think
about the double line notation
to make your computation easier,
and then even after you reach
the staff and then you need
to know this kind of topology,
et cetera.
After you reach this
staff, still, there
is a roadblock here.
But 't Hooft found a very
simple way to go around it.
Because when I say this
limit it is not well-defined,
I made the assumption that
when I go to infinity limit,
the g is kept fixed.
So that's the reason
that this will blow up.
But then 't Hooft came up
with a different image.
He said when you can see
that N goes infinity,
but at the same
time, you can see
that g squared goes to zero.
At the same time, you can see
Because the problem
with this, is
that if you have a
diagram with lots of faces
and if you multiply
by a finite number,
if you take g equal to
0, then you have infinity
multiply something
potentially goes to 0,
maybe you will get
something finite.
One second.
So you said let's
consider this limit,
so that the product of
them is kept finite.
Let's consider this limit.
So in this limit, the end
counting will be different.
So this A will be g squared
N, E minus l, because we
want to keep this fixed.
So we put an N factor here,
then we take the N factor out.
N plus F plus V
minus E. And then
let me just write this
slightly differently.
So this is Lambda.
If I use this notation,
Lambda now is finite.
So this is E minus
V. So let me just
write it as Lambda L minus
1 N to the power of Chi.
Now, let me explain [INAUDIBLE].
First, L is equal
to E minus V plus 1,
is the number of
loops in the diagram.
So do you guys remember this
formula, why this is true?
The reason this is true is
very easy to understand.
So if you look at the Feynman
diagram, the number of loops
is exactly the
same as the number
of undetermined momentum.
And each propagator will carry
momentum, and at each vertex,
you have momentum conservation.
But then this overall
momentum conservation,
which is guaranteed, so the
number of independent momentum
is E minus V and then plus 1.
Yeah, it's just E
minus V minus 1,
because there's only V
minus 1 independent momentum
constraints.
So this is the number of
independent momentums,
and so this is the
number of loops.
And the Chi is just defined
to be the number of faces
plus the number of vertices
minus the number of edge.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there any--
in general, is there
a relation between E, V, and
F, like are they completely
independent to each other?
HONG LIU: E, V, and F?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HONG LIU: Yeah, that
I'm going to explain.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: So the reason
that you can take the F
to infinity limits
without taking it
to 0, is that why we can't
apply this to QCD to get a--
HONG LIU: No, because
we apply this.
AUDIENCE: But if g is not small?
HONG LIU: It doesn't matter.
So this is an expansion scheme.
And you can apply
it to QCD, then
you can ask whether this
particular expansion scheme is
a good approximation or not.
That's a separate question.
And the focus is pretty
good, it's not that bad.
Yeah, focus of each
squaring is finite.
AUDIENCE: But it's [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: No, here
it does not tell you
if lambda has to be small.
Lambda can be very big here.
It just tells you the lambda
in this limit has to be finite.
Lambda can be convening
and it can be very big.
And actually, in the
future, we will take lambda
to go to infinity.
So now, in order to have
a well-defined limit
still depends on this chi.
So now, you ask why this works
because we still have this chi,
but now again, we need
another piece of mathematics.
First, when you
draw, let me remind
you some diagram
we had last time,
so this is the simplest diagram.
And there's a lot of
non-planar diagrams
which you can draw
on the torus, which
is the non-planar version
of this, et cetera.
And you can also have
more complicated diagrams.
So suppose you are
on the torus, I
can consider more complicated
diagrams, like that.
For example, such diagrams.
So if you think about such
diagrams, then in a sense,
each Feynman diagram
can be considered
as a partition of the surface.
So if you draw a diagram of
the surface into polygons.
Yeah, it's very clear here.
I drew this now with wavy
lines, just make them straight.
And this one topologically,
I can just draw like this,
and then I have one, one, and
the other part, similarly here.
So each Feynman diagram
can be concealed
if you just partition whatever
surface you draw the diagram.
Is this clear to you?
So this is a very
important point.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat that?
HONG LIU: Yes.
Look at this diagram.
So this is a Feynman
diagram drawn on the torus.
Does this look like a partition
of torus into polygons?
Yes, so that's what
I'm talking about.
And the statement that this
would apply for any Feynman
diagrams.
Yes, so this is like a
partition of a sphere.
You separate a sphere into
three regions, one, two, three.
Any questions about this thing?
Yes, do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, in that case
the third one isn't abandoned,
is it?
The third--
HONG LIU: So this one
I am going to show you,
you should view the
plane as a sphere.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
HONG LIU: Topologically,
it's the same as a sphere.
So now, once you
recognize this, now you
can use a famous
theorem due to Euler.
Some of you could have learned
it in junior in high school,
because the-- so this theorem,
given a surface composed
of polygons-- so if you're
not familiar with this,
you can go to Wikipedia-- with F
faces, E edges, and V vertices.
Suppose you have a surface
like this, and then
this particular
combination chi, which
is defined to be F plus V
minus E is precisely equal
to 2 minus h.
So this is the-- this is why
this is called Euler's number.
And they only depend
on the topology.
So this combination only depends
on the topology of the surface
and nothing else.
So we can imagine 't Hooft a
very good high school student.
So he already knew this.
So now, we can
rewrite this thing
as A, reading script A lambda
to the power L minus 1 N
to the power 2 minus 2h.
So remember h is
greater than zero.
So now this expression
has a well-defined limit.
So now this has a well-defined
analogy and limit.
So to the leading order,
and in particular,
this N dependence only depends
on the topology of the diagram.
Only depend on the
topology of the diagram.
For example, to leading
order in large N,
then the leading order will be
given by the planar diagrams.
Because that should
be the diagrams with h
equal zero because
h is not negative.
So the leading term
is given by h zero.
So all of the planar
diagrams in this limit,
in this so-called
't Hooft limit,
will have N dependence
which is in N squared.
N squared.
So now if you go
back to your loads,
above the fourth diagram
we started last time,
above the two planar diagrams
you can immediately
tell that indeed it
is N squared in this limit.
Then you still haven't
explained in terms of lambda.
So you can do Feynman
diagrams, et cetera.
Say lambda just depends
on the number of loops.
So if you have one
loop, then start it
with a lambda equal to zero,
start it with some constant.
If it's two loops, then lambda,
three loops, lambda squared,
et cetera.
So the sum of four--
sum of all planar
diagrams, we have
this structure.
So you can imagine
you can sum all this,
if you're powerful enough.
And then you can write
it as N squared, then
some function of lambda.
So the planar diagram would
be just N squared time
some function of lambda.
So if you are powerful enough to
compute this f0 lambda exactly,
then you can say you
have solved the planar.
You have solved the large
N limit of this series.
Unfortunately for lambda being
in gauge theory we cannot do
that.
We don't know how
to compute this.
We can on only compute
perturbatively which
actually does not work for QCD.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: But N
going to be infinite.
It just seems like-- why does
this overcome the same problem
that we had before?
HONG LIU: Because this
is a specific power.
Here there's no specific power.
That F can be as
large as you want.
AUDIENCE: But wasn't
the other problem also
that N was going to infinity?
HONG LIU: No that's
another problem.
Because here, there is a
specification limit, when
you take N going to infinity.
In there, there's
no specific limit.
There's no limit when you
take N go to infinity.
No, the limit is N squared.
I can say-- this is
your essentially,
your vacuum energy, right?
I can say E0,
divided by N squared
has a well defined limit.
So the key is that this is
a specific dependence on N.
But there it's unbounded.
AUDIENCE: I guess
another question
is, we didn't assume that
lambda is a small prohibiter.
HONG LIU: No we did
not assume lambda.
AUDIENCE: So isn't this kind
of perturbative analysis,
saying that that series
converges to some function,
is that OK?
HONG LIU: It's a very good
question, and it is OK.
But the reasoning
is more complicated.
The reasoning is
more complicated.
The keys are falling.
What I'm writing here
you can understand
using two perspectives.
Just one is heuristic.
Just one say, suppose you can
only do perturbation series,
and that would be the
thing you compute.
And then say, if you
are powerful enough
to solve the theory
with perturbity,
then you're guaranteed just to
find some general functions.
Yeah but whether
this series actually
converges is an important
mathematical question,
of course, one has to answer.
It turns out, actually
this is convergent.
You can mathematically
prove this is convergent,
for very simple reasons.
Yeah this is a side remark,
but let me mention it
because this is a cool fact.
So if you do just
lambda of g 5, 4 series,
just do the standard
Feynman diagram
calculation, input
the basic series,
the series is divergent.
The series is
divergent, no matter how
g is small, just as the
radius of convergence
is 0 for any non-zero value.
Yeah the radius of convergence
is 0 in terms of g,
no matter how small g is.
The reason that
it's divergent is
because the number of diagrams.
So when you go to Nth order, it
increases exponentially in N.
So the coefficient of
g-- say to the power
N-- the coefficient
can become huge.
Because of the
number of diagrams
to increase exponentially
in N. So you think,
I have g to the power N times N
factorial, something like that.
And that series
is not convergent.
But the thing that
is convergent here,
because can see the planar
diagram, the number of planar
diagram is very, very small.
It only increases with
N as a power of N,
rather than as a
factorial of N. And so you
can make lambda small enough,
then this can be convergent.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Didn't we already see
at the end of the last lecture
that only planar diagrams keep
the biggest contribution, so
why is that equal to--
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: So at the end of the
last lecture, we saw that--
HONG LIU: No not necessarily.
That is only for
the two diagrams.
If you look at this thing, I
can draw arbitrary complicated
non-planar diagrams, with
a very large F. They only
depend on F. It does not
depend on anything else,
if you do this.
OK so in general,
then of course if you
include the higher non-planar
diagram, et cetera--
so in general the vacuum
energy, which you would normally
call log z.
OK log z is, essentially, the
sum of all vacuum diagrams.
So this is the
partition functions,
so it's a path integral.
So log z, then we'll
have the expansion from h
equal to 0 to infinity,
N two the power 2
minus 2h, F h lambda.
OK so at each genus
level, you will
have some function of lambda.
Yeah the leading, order
we just showed is f0.
And then if you add
the Taurus now--
we'll add to the torus now
our on non-planar diagram.
It's order one.
And then, for the
two genus, it's
f over n squared, et cetera.
So let me just write
down z explicitly.
Z is the partition
function, i S phi.
So if you compute this, with
the right boundary condition--
if you compute
this path integral,
with the proper
boundary conditions,
then that gives you
the vacuum diagrams.
The log z is the sum of all
connected vacuum diagrams.
I should say, the sum of all
Any questions regarding this?
Good.
Now there is a heuristic way we
can understand this expansion.
So it's actually a
heuristic way to understand
this one-way expansion.
So let's just look at
this path integral.
So let's look at the Lagrangian.
So the Lagrangian I wrote there.
In this 't Hooft
limit, I can write it
as minus N divided by lambda.
So I want to write things
in terms of lambda.
So I multiply the pre-factor N
downstairs, and then upstairs.
So g squared N give me lambda.
And then I have a
trace, et cetera.
So now it's easy to see
that you're leading order,
this things should give
you order N squared.
Because there is already a
factor of N here, and the trace
is the sum of N things.
So generically, this should
be of the order N squared.
So now we-- a little
bit leap of faith--
say supposing the large N
limit, since the leading order
is order N squared, you can
argue that actually all the N
squared is the
expansion parameter,
if you do scatter
point approximation.
And then naturally, you
will see the power will
be given by 1 over N squared.
any questions regarding this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What does N
over lambda factor to?
HONG LIU: It's--
AUDIENCE: OK.
HONG LIU: So clearly
this discussion
actually does not-- so
when I say clearly here,
it requires a little
bit of practice.
But clearly, our
discussion only depend
on the matrix nature of the
Lagrangian and the fields.
So I'm going to make a claim.
It says for any Lagrangian,
of matrix valued fields
of the form L, which is N
divided by some coupling
constant, times a
trace of something.
Doesn't matter what you
put inside the trace
here, as far as you
have a single trace.
Such a series will always
have the expansion like this.
It will always have an
expansion like this.
So let me just summarize.
In the 't Hooft limit--
by 't Hooft limit,
I always mean this form-- the
coupling constant is defined
such that you have some
coupling concept here,
and then you have over N factor.
And then of course, you can
also have some coupling constant
inside here.
It doesn't matter.
As far as those coupling
constants are independent of N.
And as far as things inside
the trace are independent of N.
So for such a kind of series,
the 1 over N expansion
is equal to the
topological expansion.
It's the expansion in terms of
topology of Feynman diagrams.
So this is a very,
very beautiful--
and as I said, it's [INAUDIBLE],
because in principle, it
puts a very simple structure
into something that's,
in principle, very complicated.
Yeah, any questions
regarding this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Maybe it's not
can I just understand it
in such a way that he
kind of treats the Feynman
diagram as a triangulation
of different spaces.
HONG LIU: Yeah for example, you
can think of from that point.
Yeah, so we use that to
derive, to use this formula.
Yeah and that picture will be
very useful in a little bit
from now on.
Keep that picture in mind.
The Feynman diagram is like
the partition of some surfaces.
And that will be
very useful later.
AUDIENCE: Does there
ever arise a situation
in which you care not
about two surfaces,
but Feynman diagrams on
three surfaces or something
like that?
Because this asks
the question, you
don't necessarily
have to consider
the topology of two surfaces.
Are there any situations in
which it's more complicated?
HONG LIU: Yeah but we
always draw Feynman diagrams
on the paper, which
is two dimensional.
Yeah it's enough.
Two dimensions is enough.
You don't need to go
to three dimensions.
Yeah and this
structure only comes
when you go to two
dimensions, because if you
go to three dimension, of
course, they don't cross.
In three dimension,
you can no longer
distinguish planar or
non-planar diagram.
AUDIENCE: Well if you did-- OK.
HONG LIU: Good any
other questions?
AUDIENCE: Why is it always
orientable surfaces?
HONG LIU: That's
a good question.
It's because those lines
are orientable because when
we draw the double
roation, so you
have this two, double rotation.
So essentially those
lines are orientable.
They have a direction.
And essentially, this is,
of course, one and two.
Yeah so those Feynman diagrams
actually have a direction,
have a sense of orientation.
So I'm going to mention,
by passing in nature,
but let me just
mention also now.
So if it's not
[INAUDIBLE] matrix,
say if it's a real symmetric
matrix, then the then
there's no difference
between two index.
And then there's no orientation.
And that would be related
to m orientable surfaces.
And then you need to
slightly generalize this.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Now you
mentioned that it
has something to do
with string theory,
but does that it has anything
to do with scatter particles--
HONG LIU: Yeah, so we're
going to talk about that.
No, we're going to
talk about that.
Good?
So now let me talk about
general observables.
I think we're a little
bit short on time,
if we want to reach
the punchline today.
So right now we only have
looked at the vacuum diagrams.
So now let's look at
the general observables.
Before talking about
general observables,
let me just again
make a side remark,
Which is the gauge
versus global symmetries.
So in the example
we talk about here--
let me call this a, equation a.
Then let me write
down another equation
b, which is a Yang-Mills theory.
So the difference between
a and b-- so a is this guy.
So the difference
between a and b,
is that a, as we
discussed last time,
is invariant on the
global symmetry,
is a U(N) global symmetry.
It's that phi is invariant under
the acting of a unitary matrix.
But this U must be constant.
Only for a constant
U is this a symmetry.
But if you have studied a
little bit of gauge theory,
or if you have not
studied gauge theory,
just take my word
for it, the b is
invariant under a local
symmetry, a local U(N)
symmetry.
He said A miu-- so
A mu is what make up
the F-- U x A mu x, U dagger
x minus i partial mu U x.
It doesn't matter.
The only thing I want to say
is that this U x is arbitrary.
It can have arbitrary
space time dependence.
Just like of the
generalization of the QED,
it's the gauge symmetry.
So the key difference
between the two.
the key difference between this
local and the global symmetry,
are manifested in what kind of
observables we can see there.
For example, for a--
AUDIENCE: I think that should
be U dagger, partial mu and then
U dagger.
HONG LIU: HONG LIU:
So this difference,
you can say what's the big deal?
in one case, this is
constant, and this
is dependent on space time.
So the key difference
between them
is that in the case for a,
operator like this phi squared,
phi is a matrix.
So phi squared is a matrix.
Phi squared x is an
allowed operator.
So this operator is
not invariant under
this global U(N) symmetry.
But it doesn't matter because
this is a global symmetry.
So this is an allowed operator.
But if you have gauge
symmetry, all operators
must be gauge invariant.
That means that
all operator must
be invariant under this
kind of transformations.
So the analog of this
is not allows operators.
So observables in the gauge
theory are much more limited.
So we will be interested
gauge theories.
We will be interested
in gauge theories.
So that means we are always
interested in observables,
which are invariant
under the symmetry.
So we're interested
in gauge theories.
So that means we're always
interested in gauge invariant
operators.
So the kind of Lagrangian
does not matter.
So you can have
the gauge fields.
You can also have
some other field,
say some matrix phi, et cetera.
As phi is the Lagrangian
of this form, it's OK.
We always only consider the
Lagrangian of that form.
But it doesn't have an
arbitrary number of fields,
and with arbitrary
kind of interactions.
So you start your theory.
So let's for simplicity, this
can see the local operators.
In this kind of theory, then
allowed, say local operators,
must always have some
kind of trace in it.
Say you must have some
form trace, F mu U, F mu U,
a trace phi squared, et cetera.
A trace phi to some power F N,
phi to some power k, et cetera.
You can also have operators
with more than one
trace, say trace phi squared,
trace F mu U, F mu U.
So we are going to
make a distinction
because the operator
with only a single trace,
we call them single
trace operator.
And the operator with
more than one trace,
we call them multiple
trace operators.
OK so the reason for this
distinction will be clear soon.
So multiple trace operators--
it's self-evident again--
that multiple trace
operators can always
be written as products of
single trace operators.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Is it a possible case to have a
local gauge invariant operator,
the F mu U times F mu U?
HONG LIU: Yeah I always can
see the local gauge invariant
operators.
We can see the gauge theories.
AUDIENCE: So this combination,
F mu U times F mu U, it's only--
HONG LIU: No this
is gauge invariant.
AUDIENCE: Is that the only
gauge invariant component?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Is this is
the only gauge invariant
component that we can use
to construct the gauge
invariant local operators?
HONG LIU: Sorry, I don't quite
understand what you mean.
No this is just one
specific operator.
No, you can take F to the power
N, an arbitrary number of-- as
far as they're inside the trace,
it's always gauge invariant.
AUDIENCE: I see.
HONG LIU: I'm just writing
down a particular example.
So just for
notational simplicity,
I will just write-- so
from now on I will just
denote the single trace
operators collectively just
as O with some script
n, which denotes
the different operators.
so n denotes
different operators.
And then for the multiple trace
operator, then you have O1, O2.
That would be a
double trace operator.
And O1, O2, O3,
say times O3 would
be a triple trace operator.
n just labels
different operators.
I'm just using
abstract notation.
And the reason for this-- a
distinction will be clear soon.
Then for such gauge theories,
the general observables,
in the quantum field theory
is just correlation functions
of gauge invariant operators.
So by gauge invariant
operators, you
can have local operators,
non-local operators, et cetera.
So for simplicity, I will
restrict my discussion only
on the local operators.
But local operators
means that the fields
evaluated at a single point.
So the typical
correlation functions,
then the typical observables
will have this form,
will be just a product of
some correlation functions,
a product of some operators,
and I say their correlation
functions.
By c I mean the connected
correlation functions.
So you can see
immediately, these multi
trace operators are
just the product
of a single trace operator.
And the correlation function
of a multiple trace operator
can be obtained from those
of a single trace one.
You just identify
some of the acts.
Then that will be enough.
So we only need to talk about
the correlation function
of single trace operators.
So now the question-- let
me call this equation one.
So now the question follows
what we discussed before,
is how do we decide the
N dependence of the guy?
Previously we determined
the N dependence
of this vacuum diagrams
of this petition function.
But now want should
be the N dependence
of general
correlation functions?
One way to do it, you just
start immediately calculating.
And then you can find
some root, et cetera.
But actually there's
a very simple trick.
There's a very simple
trick to determine
the N dependence of this.
So now I will explain.
Now I will tell you.
So I will not give
you any examples
because this trick is so nice,
and it just works very easy.
And so the question, what
is N dependence of one?
So this is the question
we want to address.
so here is a very
simple, beautiful, trick.
So let's consider the following
generating functional.
So in quantum field
theory, when we
talk about
correlation functions,
it's always convenient to
talk about the generating
functional.
So whatever is your field,
you do the path integral
of all fields.
And then you look at the action.
So you have your regional
action, which I call S0.
And then that's add
those operators.
Ji x, O i x.
Yes so this is a standard story.
When you take the
derivative over Ji,
then you will bring
down a factor of O i.
Then that essentially give
you the correlation function.
You have, for example,
a correlation function,
the connected
correlation function.
O n, the connected
correlation function
would be just you take
the derivative of log z.
And then delta J1 x delta Jn xn.
And then you set
J equal to zero.
You set all the J equal to zero.
And that gives you the
end point function.
I should write i here,
so i to the power n.
So now here is the
beautiful trick.
You can determine this
in a single shot, the N
dependence of this guy.
And this simple trick
is just to add N here.
You add N here.
In order to get the
correlation function,
we need to divide it by
N to the power N. Now you
wanted to get O i, you need
to divide-- take the root of N
times Ji, so you also need
to divide it by 1 over N.
But why does this help?
Why does this help?
It helps for the
following reason.
Let me call this whole
thing iS effective.
iS effective, so
the key thing is
that this O i, single
trace operators,
then this S effective
then has the form
N times the trace something.
Because you already know S0,
which is our starting point,
has this form.
And now the term you added in,
precisely, also has this form,
is the N factor times
something single trace.
So that means the whole
thing still has this form.
Then now we can
immediately conclude
this log z J1, Jn, must
have this expansion.
h from 0 to infinity,
and to the 2 minus 2h, f
h lambda J1, et cetera.
So adding that N is a
powerful, powerful trick.
So now you can immediately,
just from here,
we can immediately find out
that for endpoint function,
connected endpoint function,
the leading order is 2 minus n,
because the leading
order is n squared.
Yeah it's 2 minus n.
And then suppressed by 1
over N squared, et cetera.
Good?
So for example, if you look
at a 0 point function, which
is essentially the partition
function, so this is order
N squared.
So this is what we found
before, to leading order.
And if you look at the
one point function,
some operator,
then, will be order
N. If you look at the two point
function, connected two point
function of some operator,
so it would be order one.
And the three point
function of some operator
will be order 1 over N,
as the leading order.
And then all higher order
just down by 1 over N
squared, compared to
the leading order.
And again, the leading order is
given by the planar diagrams.
Because of the leading
order contribution to here,
in terms of this S
effective is planar diagram.
And then they must be,
under those things,
just obtained by through
[INAUDIBLE], so they
must be planar diagrams.
so again this comes
from planar diagrams.
Good?
So now let's talk about the
physical implications of this.
So what does this mean?
So we have found out, this is
our N dependence for our gauge
invariant operators.
So what does this mean?
Now let me talk about
physical implications.
AUDIENCE: What did one of
those [INAUDIBLE] have with--
HONG LIU: Yeah, I
defined them without chi.
AUDIENCE: Then something like--
HONG LIU: You define something.
So when you write
down your theory,
you define this 't Hooft limit.
Then everything is
already in terms of lambda
or some other order one number.
So that can depend on those
numbers in an arbitrary way.
It doesn't matter can
depend on coupling constants
in an arbitrary, but it cannot
have N dependence defined
inside the operator.
Once we introduce
this 't Hooft limit,
then the operator can depend
on the coupling in the 't Hooft
limit in an arbitrary way.
Because they're all just
all the one constant.
Let's talk about physical
implications of this.
It turns out, these simple
and [INAUDIBLE] behavior
actually has a very simple
physical picture behind it.
So first he said, in the
large N limit-- so let's just
look at leading order behavior.
So in a large N limit, if
we consider this state of O
i x acting on the vacuum.
So some single trace operator
acting on the vacuum.
So i, again, just
labels different state,
different operators.
These can be interpreted as
creating a "single particle"
state.
I'm first describing
the conclusion.
Then I will explain why.
So you can see that
the state obtained
by adding a single trace
operator on the vacuum,
then this can be interpreted
as a single particle state.
So if you add on the double
trace operator on the vacuum,
then this can be interpreted
as two particle state.
Similarly, say O n
acting on the vacuum
would be N particle states.
So why is this so?
Why this is so.
So I will support this
statement using three arguments.
First remember O i O j, the
connecting Green function
of any two operators
of order one.
So we can actually
just diagonalize them.
If you can just diagonalize
them, so that O i O j
are proportional to delta i j.
So in some sense, a
two point function,
those operators can be
considered as independent.
And now the second statement.
So if you want to call
this single particle,
this two particle, multi
particle, then they
should be that
they don't overlap.
Because a single particle cannot
overlap with two particle,
et cetera.
And then to see the overlap
between a single particle
with a multi particle, you look
at these correlation functions.
So if you look at the overlap
of a single particle state,
with a two particle state, say
some double trace operator.
Let me just, to
avoid confusion, let
me just use the inside--
use this notation
to see this as a
single operator.
So you can see
that the overlap we
saw of the single trace
operator with this double trace
operator.
And they start off--
this whole thing
is like a three point function.
Just put these two
over the same point.
So from our discussion here,
is how you connect the Green
functions of order 1 over N.
So this goes to 0, compared
to this overlap with itself.
So that means in the N
goes to infinity limit,
there is no mixing between
what we called single particle
state, single trace, and
the multiple trace states.
So the third thing
is that now let's
look at the two point function
of two double trace operator.
So O1 O2 x, say O1 O2 and y.
OK double trace operators.
So let's look at the
two point function
with double trace operators.
So there's an even
contribution to this.
So let's include all diagrams.
Also these can all be
connected So leading order
is a disconnected diagram,
which is essentially
O1 x O1 y and O2 x and O2 y.
Because I have a
diagonal next to them.
have And then plus
the connected Green
functions, which is
order 1 over N squared.
So if you see this leading
order contribution,
it's just like two independent
particle propagating.
Just like the product of
two independent propagators.
So it's sensible
to interpret this
as just the propagating
of two particles.
So it's sensible to
interpret this two particle
state, this double
trace operator
as just creating some
two particle state.
Yeah, again this goes to
zero, in the large N limit.
So I should emphasize when we
call this a single particle
state, it's not
necessary they really
exist on a shell particle
corresponding to this state.
We're just saying that the
behavior of these states
can be interpreted as some
kind of single particles.
The behavior you can just
interpret as single particles.
It's not really
necessary they exist
as stable on shell particles.
In certain cases,
there might be.
There might be actual
particles, actual stable,
on shell particles associated
with these kind of states.
But for this
interpretation to be true,
it does not have to be.
So in QCD actually sometimes--
so I just say they exist.
So we call them
"glueball" state.
For example, in QCD, the
analog of this kind of operator
can create some state,
which they are short-lived.
They are not long-lived.
They quickly decay.
And so they're typically
called the glueball state.
So from now on we just
call them glueballs.
Call them glueballs.
So this is one of the
first implication--
the first indication
is that they're just
a single particles.
A single trace operator
can be interpreted
as creating single
particle states,
and the multiple
trace operator can
be interpreted as creating
multi particle states.
Another second, he said if
this glueball operators, so
fluctuations of
glueballs suppressed.
So let me explain
what this means.
So let me suppose some
single trace operator, O,
which has a non-zero
expectation value,
suppose some state has a
non-zero expectation value.
And then let's look at the
variance of this operator,
the variance of the
expectation value, which
is given by O squared, minus
O squared for the fluctuation.
And this is, by definition, just
a collected Green function of O
squared.
The is the full O squared.
This is the disconnected one.
So this is just a collected
part of the O squared.
And this one, N
dependence, we know
this is order one,
order N to the power 0.
So that means that these
to below this order
N. So the variance of this,
compared to the expectation
value of this operator itself is
surprising, the large N limit.
So essentially, in
the large N limit,
so that means the variance
provided by the operator
itself is 1 over N because of
the 0 in the large N limit.
So assuming that if you have
a two point function-- so
suppose each two point
function, so each O2
have a non-zero
expectation value,
then you can factorize
this O1 O2, plus O1 O2.
So this is disconnected part.
And again this will
be of order one.
But this part is
of order N squared.
So essentially the disconnected
the part is always factorized.
So the disconnected part
is always factorized.
Yeah this connected
part is always small,
compared to the
disconnected part.
So this is like a
classical theory.
AUDIENCE: We have
just five minutes.
We can proceed before it's 5:00
HONG LIU: Yeah but it
may go to 10 minutes.
It's just hard to say.
Yeah, let me do it next time.